[Music]
trap yours my friend
it really is hard to believe it has been
more than 25 years since Queens
legendary lead singer Freddie Mercury
passed away while his incredible life
story is finally headed to the big
screen and we spoke to the man who will
take on this daunting role will you be
doing Freddie Mercury's that troupe I'm
playing Freddie Mercury how about that
rami malek who won an Emmy playing mr.
robots Elliot Alderson a cybersecurity
hacker now has the challenge of playing
Mercury's the flashy frontman for queen
with a four octave range
[Music]
will you sing well I think I will sing a
little bit I will sing a little bit why
not all for it is Romi's mr. robot
co-star Christian Slater we share
dressing rooms I put a cup up and I hear
him singing in there and it's gonna blow
everybody away Romney his game lease on
camera before in his former Fox sitcom
the war at home producing the music will
be surviving bandmates Brian May and
Roger Taylor I've taken my bags
directed by x-men franchise producer
Bryan Singer and slated to start
shooting early this year the film is
called Bohemian Rhapsody getting to this
point has been a torturous eight years
chameleon Sacha Baron Cohen was slated
to play mercury but dropped out because
of so-called
creative differences basically they
wanted to make a movie about the band
and I want to make head kind of a little
more about Freddy's British actor Ben
Whishaw q in the recent Bond movies was
then mentioned but reportedly dropped
out because of scheduling problem the
focus of the film is said to be the
band's formative years and back in 1982
Freddie told us they weren't easy
I never wanted easy I don't want anybody
to make it easy for me it's like cuz I'm
I'm a survivor I want to work hard for
it and bad mistakes
I've met a few I cannot wait to see this
I hope we get to come on the set and
check you out I make that I make sir I'm
geeked up about that I'm geeked up no
pressure
no I'm stoked to I mean one of the most
iconic bands ya ever and just to be a
part of that huge
we are the jack
[Music]
you